let's talk about the gay mafia because
that's been the big story this week
because Bill Maher on overtime which is
the online only show that they do on
real time after the show he implied that
there actually is a gay mafia let's take
a look what do you think of the Mozilla
CEO having to step down over his
donation to pro proposition 8 group yeah
the Mozilla which I'm wearing right now
by the way I didn't know what Mozilla
was I saw it on my computer but it's
it's Firefox right it's the okay so this
guy apparently does not want gay people
to get married and he had to step down
what do you think of that the question
is because he gave $1,000 eight years
ago and it's coming back to haunt him
when he gave it when President Obama is
still was against gay marriage so I
don't think it's very fair good point
also I think there is a gay mafia I
think if you crossed them you do get why
I really do
okay I think there was some odd sexual
connotations for the way he said whacked
wasn't there something there there's
something something seemed a little
bizarre okay so they talked a little bit
about the Mozilla CEO as we just did in
the previous segment but he the way bill
says it he's half joking but the way
he's sort of leaning in his chair is
also like yeah I'm in this thing I'm in
Hollywood I'm pretty entrenched and I
know this thing exists so you two
professional gay people does the gay
mafia exist Davey wavey no comment how
much is gonna pay you don't think
there's an organized group of gay people
that are meeting somewhere that are
powerful it's not that organized I think
there's a group of gay I think they're
gay friends circles as there are in any
professional setting and they do favors
for each other I don't believe that
anyone is pulling strings
Yeah right so when the right-wing people
because we've got a list of things that
people claim that the gay mafia does
they say that you know they started the
firestorm a duck dynasty thing that was
the gay mafia but then the gay mafia
lost that one I guess cuz duck dynasty
alec baldwin everybody's favorite hate
monger he lost his gig at MSNBC that
must be the gay mafia and then the CEO
obviously of mozilla so you guys really
don't you just don't believe well I
think what there is is probably a group
of very wealthy gay men that get
together and decide like what Kent what
candidates they're gonna find where
they're gonna put their money the things
that they're gonna try to influence with
their dollars I don't think that they're
like thinking that they're gonna make
some firestorm about duck dynasty I
think that was a media yeah and and I
think the with the Firefox like it's
it's it's public opinion that that this
guy was like gay mafia now is public
opinion that's why he stepped down okay
so I that I agree with that what they're
calling gay mafia really is just glad
HRC the rest of that stuff which whether
you like those organizations or not
every group in this country has their
advocacy groups that are trying to to do
things would it be the worst thing in
the world if we actually had a gay mafia
if they really if it came out but yes
there is a group of gay people trying to
pull some strings so they gay people
become more equal and you see better
images of gay people immediate things
like that would that be that bad if its
phrase like that the answer is no but I
think the gay mafia are all the
fourteen-year-old white girls on Twitter
back up when they're people like you and
it'll come to your defense over
everything every host a shirtless video
it's all the fourteen-year-old girls
that click likes to your old man
yeah a YouTube video at playlist live
and I had to kiss straight guys in it
and I was like no one is gonna kiss me
look no straight guy is gonna do this
I had like 60 fourteen-year-old girls
running with me up to these guys like
alright well there you have it I have
brought on to professional gay youtubers
I know a little something about this
myself
and we don't know if there is a gay
mafia which maybe means we're on we're
on the outs probably Oh God invite us in
guys if this is really around hello
really what can we do for you